who died and but lucien in church and
what are desires well desires
here's what we know about the ending of
the sandman season one
the final episode of the sandman season
one shows the demon a zazzle egging
lucifer morningstar on with the hellish
ruler plotting to use the formite of
their armies to bring morpheus to his
knees while this strongly hints at a
full-blown war between the demons of
hell and the forces of the dreaming if
the show follows the course of the
source material this subplots will
likely end in lucifer's retirement from
being the monarch of hell perhaps even
following a similar path to that of the
lucifer that tom ellis portrayed in the
series of the same name then again the
showrunners may subvert the expectations
of longtime fans and things could unfold
on the tv show in an entirely different
manner in an interview with tv line
gwendolyn christie muse that the idea of
losing to dream must be entirely
consuming for the former favored angel
of god perhaps enough for it to dwell on
their mind and dictate their actions in
future seasons the loss in season 1
could even be considered the final
insult for them
it's your move
additionally christie revealed that her
portrayal of lucifer wasn't even
inspired by tom ellis's version to begin
with despite being a fan of the latter
she even avoided watching alice's show
so that it wouldn't influence her take
on the role and instead opted to take
inspiration from assorted material
introduced in episode 1 the corinthians
serves as the primary antagonist for the
first season of netflix says the sandman
the corinthians apparent obsession with
killing people in the waking world and
the unmistakable joy he derives from
taking a life makes him the ideal
season-long foil for morpheus aside from
being an incredibly dangerous opponent
the corinthian also represents
everything that stands against the
dream's principles while morpheus is all
about maintaining balance adhering to
predetermined roles and restoring things
to the way they were before his
disappearance the corinthian delights in
becoming an agent of chaos and murder on
earth he refuses to stick to the
responsibilities he was created to
fulfill in the sandman companion neil
gaiman confirmed that the nightmare's
name came from the word pertaining to
the behavior typically attributed to
someone from the ancient grecian region
of corinth reckless lacking in morals
and possessing a distaste for rules
given how closely the series sticks to
the events of the source material it's
highly likely that we'll see the
corinthian again in a future season
though perhaps not anytime soon despite
dream's proclamation in episode 10 that
the world doesn't need another malthus
nightmare just yet
the comic book version of the lord of
dreams does end up remaking a more loyal
less petty version of the corinthian
the beginning of netflix's sandman
series shows how a dream was captured by
roderick burgess in 1916 and kept as a
prisoner in his mansion in witchcraft
england the ruler of the dreaming is
shown to be unwavering ruthless and
inflexible in his purpose as well as his
resolve he spends a century in his
prison remaining completely silent while
being guarded round the clock by
burgess's men and when an opportunity to
escape arises morpheus swiftly takes it
however his quest to bring things back
to the way they were leads him to become
gradually but profoundly changed he
begins to realize that he has committed
mistakes drawing his rules as dreamlord
and also learns to be less rigid and
more merciful it seems i heard you an
apology
i've always had it impolite to keep
one's friends waiting
he recognizes the efforts of his
librarian lucien to keep the dreaming
running in his extended absence he also
accepts sahar's truth that he does need
friends and even shows compassion in
situations where he would normally make
cold calculated decisions in an
interview with the rap tom sturridge
revealed that he followed two principles
in his portrayal of morpheus that his
words are calculated and precise and
that he is terrifying and authoritative
yet seductive this makes a character
journey of someone as set in his ways a
stream so fascinating to watch
throughout the sandman it's an evolution
we're sure to see more of
for the uninitiated one of the most
shocking things to come out of the first
season of the sandman is the dream
pregnancy of liter hall which was
somehow carried over to the real world
thanks to rose walker's powers as a
dream vortex lita's child was conceived
when she and her dead husband hector
mess and made love in lita's dream in
the sandman season one finale lita gives
birth to a healthy child who has yet to
receive a name after surviving her
ordeal with morpheus thanks to her
grandmother unity kincaid's ultimate
sacrifice rose commits to raising the
child alongside her brother jed and lita
what new fans of the sand man may not
realize though is that the series may
have actually planted the seeds of its
finale as early as this sequence of
events
in the comics a child who is a son of
established dc superheroes dr fate and
fury receives the name daniel from
morpheus himself through a series of
complicated and ultimately tragic events
daniel grows up and discovers that he
has the power to cross over to the
dreaming eventually he becomes a new
ruler of the dreaming when morpheus dies
at the hands of the kindly ones becoming
the new dream of the endless
despite the corinthians attempts to
trick rose walker into using her dream
vortex abilities to destroy morpheus the
young woman decides to sacrifice herself
to ensure the survival of her loved ones
she avoids this phase however thanks to
the intervention of two characters the
enigmatic gilbert who is secretly an
escapee from the dreaming called
fiddler's green and rose's grandmother
unity kincaid who takes the dream vortex
from rose so that she could die in her
great-granddaughter's place
in an interview with pop verse conducted
during stcc 2022 vanessa samunai shared
that in bringing rosa dream vortex to
life she had to work on building the
character's backstory on her own this
was because they were using an early
storyline from the comics that covered
only a fraction of rose's development
she also described her role in a way
that hinted there's more to come for the
character in future seasons plus given
rose's commitment at the end of the
series to take care of her brother jed
and leads his currently unnamed child
it's almost a certainty that we'll see
the character again maybe even as early
as season two perhaps her time as a
dream vortex will come in handy when she
guides leads his child into adulthood in
dream's absence the librarian lucien
takes it upon herself to maintain order
in the dreaming whereas the other
enchanted denizens of the realm lost
faith in morpheus and left the kingdom
lucienne stayed firmly believing that
dream would return someday when morpheus
finally does make his return he starts
by being largely dismissive and
unappreciative of lucien's thoughts and
opinions by season's end though dream
places the day-to-day operations of the
realm and lucian's capable hands once
again as he focuses on creating a new
batch of dreams and nightmares would you
mind
taking care of things
while i work from the many interactions
between morpheus and lucien throughout
the sandman it's clear that the
dreaming's librarian has a deep respect
and reverence for dream despite dreams
apparent disregard for her efforts
lucien continues to work behind the
scenes to prevent the kingdom from
collapsing this is partly because she's
aware of the tremendous weight on
dream's shoulders and wants to save him
from self-ruin vivienna chempong
affirmed this in an interview with
collider calling the relationship
between the lord and the librarian very
important and special it's almost
guaranteed at this point that we'll see
lucien in future seasons of the sunman
unless the series decides to deviate
radically from the source material the
librarian of the dreaming will likely
continue to be dream's most trusted
servant
in episode 10 of the sandman season 1 we
see dream confronts his sibling desire
in the latter's realm as it turns out
the misfortunes that befell dream in the
waking world were brought about by
desire in their conversation with a
fellow endless known as despair it
becomes clear that desire harbors
massive enmity towards dream and is
willing to do anything to bring the
master of the dreaming down a few
notches while the sandman season 1
doesn't explore the deeper reasons
behind desire's malicious grudge against
stream their heated exchange during the
last episode promises that we'll see
more of this sibling rivalry in
subsequent seasons interestingly despite
the disastrous consequences of desire's
actions dream sibling doesn't see
themselves as a villain but as a hero of
their own story mason alexander park who
plays tazia states this in an interview
published by fan sided adding that the
character only really comes into
conflict with her older brother because
of their disparity in morals and
character traits among the seven
siblings who comprise the endless
audiences have only been formally
introduced to dream desire despair and
death their prodigal brother destruction
was referred to but not name dropped the
protocol
what
oh
him
no we don't get to see delirium and
destiny in season one but they're bound
to show up in future seasons especially
since park expressed her excitement of
being part of a scene where the siblings
come together
long time fans of the sandman may not
recognize ghost who plays a fairly
significant role in the first season
that's because she's a character created
for the series combining two nightmares
from the comics brute and glob while
retaining the same narrative role they
failed much like the corinthian gold
serves as an effective obstacle in
dream's way because she does not want to
follow her predetermined path her desire
to become a vision that inspires hope
rather than one that brings a person's
fear to the surface which is her actual
role as a nightmare is what prompted her
to escape from the dreaming in the first
place to watch this contrast to play out
in the few episodes she's in is a treat
especially because it doesn't get
immediately resolved when she confronts
dream rather we see her get her wish in
episode 10 when morpheus remakes her
into a dream complete with beautiful
wings this represents a significant
change not only in gold but in the
formally inflexible dream as well in a
way her rebellion helped both of them to
grow i had no right returning here after
over a century expecting everything to
be just as i'd left it since gold's
character journey has already come full
circle by the end of season one it's
unlikely that we'll see her pop up in
future seasons never say never though as
her newfound role and abilities may
still play a part in dream's future
adventures
fans who read the source material may
have expected to see some familiar faces
from the dc universe in season 1 of
netflix's sandman for starters two
superheroes strongly affiliated with the
justice league mr miracle and his
civilian identity as well as a martian
manhunter appeared during the first arc
of the comic book series the demon
etragon served the stream's guide when
he ventured to hell to retrieve his
helmet perhaps most significantly
morpheus originally had to fight the dc
supervillain dr destiny to regain the
powers contained in his ruby the netflix
series just utilized john d in this
specific role but never refers to him as
his nefarious alter ego while viewers
cannot be faulted for speculating that
the reason for their remission was
strictly due to various licensing issues
the reality appears to be a lot less
corporate driven than that at least
according to sandman creator neil gaiman
in a 2021 tumblr post a fan asked gamer
about his decision to incorporate
established dc characters into the
sandman the author responded that while
it was his desire to tap into the fabric
of the dc universe while writing sandman
the book for the show it seemed
naturally to drift away from the dc
universe into a universe that looked a
lot more like ours